GARY OLSON: We
study collaboration,
but we also practice it.
And we're going to
talk about today, it
has involved all these people,
some of whom you may know.
Julie has been an intern
here a couple of times,
and Amy is now family
member at UIUC whatever.
I'm going to do for the
first little chunk of this
and then Judy will take over
and do the second chunk of it.
As Dan mentioned, we've
been in this space
of studying collaboration
for a long time.
I think the very first
project we were involved in
was in the mid '80s.
So it's now getting
close to 30 years.
We actually built in the late
'80s a program called ShrEdit.
It was a shared editor, which
is actually functionally very
close to what Google
Docs is today.
We did a whole series
of studies, both of face
to face meetings and distributed
meetings, using ShrEdit.
So we were into this
space a long time ago.
And it's fun now for us to see
that everybody in the world
can get access to these kinds
of capabilities, which we have
developed as a research
tool many years ago.
We published this paper,
"Distance Matters,"
in year 2000.
In 2008, we published
a book, MIT Press
on "Scientific Collaboration
on the Internet."
And we just now, within
the last few weeks,
published a book
with Morgan Claypool,
called "Working Together Apart."
And the central theme
in a lot of this work
is trying to understand
the mix of technology
and social practices
that go together
to make collaboration work.
And that's the main
theme of our work.
We've explored over the years
many different technologies,
many different
kinds of situations,
small groups, large
groups and so on.
And I think we've actually
made some progress.
And in fact, this 2014
book is the latest turn
of the crank on
what we think we've
learned over this
long period of time.
We have six topics
to talk about today.
We'll talk about some
of them quite briefly.
We've been doing a
study of the roll-out
of Google Apps on
university campuses.
I'll talk a little
bit about that.
We've done some work on
how people deal with cloud.
Not so well it turns out.
Julia Haynes is doing some
work on studying collaboration
in seed accelerators.
And then we have a whole
series of microprojects,
where I'll be spending
more time on these,
then on these early ones.
So we've had an opportunity
with our support from Google
to study how Google
Apps is playing out
on a series of
university campuses.
So we've done a study on six
campuses, five UC campuses
plus university
of Michigan where
we have strong connections.
And we've actually done
a variety of things.
The main thing has been an
annual survey of undergraduates
on these campuses
about their practices
and using Google Apps.
We've done other things
like survey administrators.
We've looked into the
clubs because they turn out
to be a vector for adoption
of these technologies.
We've talked to faculty and
graduate students as well.
But I'm going to
focus here mainly
on the stuff we've done
with undergraduates.
OK let me talk briefly
about the cloud.
There's more than
one cloud obviously.
We are not alone out
there in the cloud.
One of the things we looked
at, we did a study-- primarily
Amy Voida did this
study-- an interview study
of faculty and graduate students
about their use of Google
Apps in research collaborations,
in teaching, and so on.
And one of the themes
that emerged from this
was how much trouble people
were having with the cloud.
And a whole variety of issues.
And as I say, only point
to, we had a paper at Chi
this last year.
It has a lot of detail in
it about what we found.
But for example, we found
that the average number
of email accounts in the
people we interviewed was five.
It ranged all the
way from 1 to 12.
So people are managing a whole
bunch of different identities,
not just for mail account
but for other things; cloud
services of various
kinds and so on.
And there is confusion.
It's also the case
that things don't
act the same in the cloud.
So if you're working on Google
Drive with a bunch of documents
and materials, or you're
working, say, on Drop Box,
things behave differently.
Things come and go.
Your permissions are
more complicated,
they're not the same in
the different environments,
and so on.
So just a lot of
different confusions
about what is going on, which
is why we talked about this
has thunder in the cloud.
As I say, the story is
that people are still
quite confused about this.
I think there's an
interesting follow up study
to do to see if
people are sorting out
what's happening with the cloud.
But it's a source of
confusion to a lot of people,
and you can see a lot of the
empirical details in the Chi
paper.
OK with that, any
questions about,
that was very brief
about the cloud.
Any questions?
It's not surprising that it is
a little confusing for people.
JUDY OLSON: Can you
go back one slide?
This part is the thing
that confuses me.
So when I work with
different people
they say, oh I just
put it in Drop Box.
That was the first time
I'd heard about Drop Box,
was when somebody said
well that's where I put it.
As opposed to talking
about it before and about
how we're going to manage
all of our documents.
This is several years ago.
But now, I'm looking
for a document
like the last
presentation here, and I'm
looking all over
my file structure.
Cannot find it.
What did I call it?
It should be in
the Google folder.
And it turned out, no
it was in Google Drive.
So it was 20 minutes
lost on that.
So searching over
everything, I'm not sure.
In academics any
way, we collaborate
with a lot of people and they
have lots of different habits
and so I have to think
about how we doing this one.
I want to touch
briefly on some work
to Julia Haynes is doing
about seed accelerators.
There is a delay.
Here we go.
All right.
Seed accelerators, born
in Silicon Valley, where
you bring together a
lot of entrepreneurs,
give them by the time to
learn from each other,
present to each other.
It's a big contest and at the
end there are some winners
and they get venture capital.
So the question
is, how does this
translate to places
around the world?
More and more people
are interested in this
because they want to
develop applications
for their own people,
in their own situation.
So around the world.
Julia's interviewed
a number of people
in every major geographic region
that has the seed accelerators.
She visited accelerators
in North America, Africa,
Australia, and Asia.
And then she just came back from
a three months in depth field
at one accelerator in Singapore
following nine start-ups.
And she's about to go off
to Buernos Aires, Argentina.
These are just photographs from
her particular experiences.
We have only a few
nuggets of what she found.
And I think this is really
interesting that Silicon Valley
culture does not travel well.
So US values have shared risk,
equity, accepting failure,
openness to differences,
which is the lifeblood of how
these accelerators
work around here.
Do not translate well
when you go to places,
she noticed in Asia,
where there are
values a hierarchy
status and collectivism.
And so a lot of mismatch on how
the behavior of the people is
and how they're coming
out with the ideas.
Here's a good example.
In Korea, being an entrepreneur
is being considered a failure.
Around here it's kudos
for being an entrepreneur.
But since 80% of their
gross domestic product
comes from 10 conglomerates.
If you don't work for one
of them, you're a failure.
And so the people who
are working in these seed
accelerators have a very
different cultural view
about what they're doing.
So this is all work in progress.
She'll probably
finish in a year.
And we can report back
on what she's finding.
There's a lot of stuff
happening about what's
happening inside Google Docs.
And how do we look at it,
what are the activities, how
do people really collaborate
at the much more micro level.
We've been doing a
lot of visualization
of the collaboration
inside Google Docs.
we are using a variation
of history flow, which
Fernando Villegas and
Martin Wattenberg,
developed a number of years
ago to look at Wikipedia.
Wikipedia.
So we translate that
into Google Docs.
The time goes this way.
Color is a person.
And this is just the volume
of what they are developing.
So somebody put in the
title of the document.
Somebody put in a chunk.
There's some editing.
A whole bunch more and self
editing, that black here,
it's actually a darker
orange and various kinds.
It's self editing, editing
somebody else's stuff.
A whole bunch more
added at the beginning.
This chunk maintained.
And then just lot more editing.
So this is one document.
This is another one with
a lot more activity.
And the same number
of people doing stuff
but you could see how things in
both cases, things are growing.
I'm going to show you some cases
where they don't just grow.
People will cut whole
pieces out of things.
But this is an
instant visualization
about what went on.
If you're an author of
one of these things,
what would you want to look at?
Who cut my stuff, who's editing,
where has nobody edited?
Maybe I should go in and
read some of that stuff.
Or for researchers,
just to find out,
well what's interesting in here?
Where is the good stuff, what's
the characteristics of things
that change a lot, and the
characteristics of things that
don't?
So I have 97 documents.
What's nice about
this is it's a grid.
It's the same four
or five assignments
done by lots of different teams.
And so I could say,
is this assignment
generating a signature way
of working, or at a teams
develop a signature
way of working.
So is it the document,
or is it the team?
It'll be a mix, but
it'll be interesting.
We also have some
real world documents,
that people have
developed in Google Docs.
Several big grant proposals.
And Gary's and my book
we wrote in Google Docs,
until the very end
when it had to be
translated into other formats.
And that gets interesting
because we do know,
we know the whole back story
about who wrote who and why.
GARY OLSON: And who
deleted what and why.
JUDY OLSON: And who
delayed who and why.
In our background now
the famous chapter nine,
which was written, and then
I wrote the second half
and he deleted the
whole second half.
So we had some
discussion about that.
And then he started
on the second half
and then I convinced him to
revert, and explained about,
it was a whole story.
But we really know the
back story of that one.
The famous chapter nine.
All right.
So what are we looking for.
So in these
visualizations, I was
interested in things
like that got cut.
Can you see where it just
goes up instead of down?
So that's not an addition,
that's a deletion.
So I look inside the
document and it turns out
the students are having a
conversation in the document.
It says down here, hey
guys just a bullet points
in each section.
Turn that into paragraphs later.
This is when it's due.
And that gets deleted later.
I hope you guys work on
this tonight and tomorrow.
I'd rather have
this done tonight,
especially since I
can't work after class,
but you guys might.
So that's text.
It's not a comment,
it's text in there.
And then later of
course, they delete it,
because it has to be all
cleaned up and stuff for me.
The other thing that was
interesting in this particular
document is, how much heavy
editing there is here.
This part stays pretty stable.
This part has everybody in it,
so I wanted them to go and look
and what's in there, what
were they discussing,
is this the business case?
So pitching their idea
for a particular project.
I think that this
is going to lead
to high quality, when
everybody's in it.
As opposed to you do part
one, I'll do part two.
Here was a surprise.
And of course, I went right
back to the algorithms saying,
what's going on
here, is this a bug?
The answer is no.
They started working
on this document
and orange guy came in here
and deleted the whole thing.
Said this is a mess.
And what he pasted in was a
template for a scope statement.
And then he said,
well not all of this
is relevant for us, in
fact this whole second half
we don't need.
And then they started
fleshing out what was in that.
But he said the structure
of this is a mess,
and so I'm going
to just start over.
So again, we've got some
things, big things cut.
And a great big thing
at the end that was cut.
And this started
giving us ideas about,
well what is the API giving us?
So if you look in this
particular document,
this again is a conversation at
the beginning where everybody's
saying, how do you
use Google Docs?
They're teaching each other.
And then of course,
that's not going
to be in the final document.
These turn out to be
comments unattributed
to the location in
which they arose.
So that's what the API gives
us, is there's a lot of text.
And of course, somebody
came and cleaned it up
before they turned into me.
So we have to work
with the people, who
if we want to
pursue this, we want
to work with people about
what can the API give us,
both about the common
structure and then,
as you'll see in a minute,
about simultaneous work.
But this is Facebook
about three days ago.
This is Ben Bederson--
a number of you
know Ben-- saying
I just finished
creating my most complicated
spreadsheet ever with Google
Spreadsheets to support a
collaborative review by six
people of 30 proposals.
So instead of using
one application that's
out there like what manuscript
central and stuff like that,
he did it in Google
Spreadsheets.
It replicates the basic
conference review system
but without any code.
Is complicated enough.
And so he's showing
a piece of it
to give us ideas
about what you do,
that's collaborative but
structured by somebody
at the beginning.
My favorite comment is
from his wife down here.
Alison Druin said
something about geekiness
that he's going to broadcast
all of this on Facebook.
So we've been looking
at spreadsheets.
Did an interview study,
a short study about,
who's using spreadsheets
collaboratively and for what.
There's a TV show
production crew.
There's an evaluator
and clinical reporting
at mental health facility.
Manager billing, senior
contract and grant analysts,
all of which are using
spreadsheets collaboratively.
So early findings on this.
Knowing who created what in a
spreadsheet is very important.
You want to know to audit or
check things as they change.
It could be of value
it could be a formula.
They brainstorm
about the structure
and then roles about
who will fill in what.
It's very structured about the
roles and responsibilities.
People asked
permission to change
things they didn't originate.
And changing
formulas or structure
is critically more important
than changing values,
because it's all hidden
and not revealed very well.
There are visualization of
formula structures, like which
cells are involved,
that already come
with a number of
spreadsheet applications.
But we'd like to
look at authorship
and values and things like this.
A very complicated
problem, because it's
very multi-dimensional.
We have other things
we've been playing with.
One is just how much activity
is there in a particular cell.
And then some basic statistics
about, who did what when.
About adding structure,
adding values, editing.
So who's the major
editor and how
did this progress over time?
So this is as far as
we are on spreadsheets.
Ideas welcome about how
to develop this further.
The problem is that it's
a two dimensional thingy.
And I think we're going to
have to use animation in it.
Or decide from the
end users, which
are the things that are
most important for them
to find out, and then do
some analysis of that.
That's it on where we are in
visualization of collaboration.
As I say, lots of ideas welcome.
On that they are tough problems.
The second is, we have to
be careful about saying more
is better, because it might
be the small things that make
something good or the
final structure of being
in a single voice
and not being abrupt.
The next set of studies, we are
embarking on is about quality.
Does the document
have better content.
Does it cohere?
What could we detect to alert
authors too low quality.
And what social practices
make a good document.
So that's the next chunk
of work that we're doing.
Several of us think
that the heavy editing
of each other's work suggests
that there may be contentions
or it may be somebody's cleaning
things up to make it one voice
or to make it cohere.
So that would be sessions that
we would look at about where,
are these and what
actually is going on.
We're going to have to do some
quality assessments of what's
going on, does this
actually make it better.
But we would like to do as
much as we can automatically.
And so we're
working on something
we called Novox,
which is new voice.
We analyze the text for
style changes in particular.
So the back story here is
that a co editor of a book
called Ways of Knowing in HCI,
and some people in the room
are chapter authors.
GARY OLSON: Authors.
JUDY OLSON: Yes.
There are 19 chapters in
the book and 39 authors.
So there are a lot of
co-authored chapters.
And in some of the early
drafts, I as an editor,
could immediately tell
that the voice changed.
And then there would be a
comment back to the people ,
make this one voice.
Well I think we can
do better than that.
What is it that I'm picking up?
What kind of a
linguistic analysis
can we do to figure out
that the voice has changed,
and something has to be
made more coherent in style?
We don't need to do the
kinds of linguistic analysis
to find out whether
Shakespeare wrote Shakespeare.
All I need to know
is something changed.
So that's easier to
do, thank goodness.
So we would like
eventually to if we
find those abrupt changes, to
be able to alert the author,
not with a paper clip, but
with some kind of indicator
that maybe you ought to
think about this to make this
into one voice.
And eventually maybe even
to suggest, in what way
the voice has changed.
I noticed a lot of things
about the use of however,
and but, and semicolons,
bullets versus paragraphs,
the things that are
big changes in there.
We have a program
now that will look
at known indicators
of style change.
David Guthrie is here at Google.
He has done some of this
seminal work about what
are the things that are
indicators of style change.
Function words, not the
content, but the function words.
Average sentence length,
syllables per word.
So he writes at a level
that's for graduate students
and I write for
elementary school kids,
you're going to be
able to pick that up.
In sentence like and
the kinds of words.
We have a corpus
that we are building.
Some we actually know the
answer who wrote what,
because we have revision
histories in Google.
So we can be blind
to that and then
check our algorithms
to see whether we
got the change in voice.
So we're working
on this right now,
we have an analysis of
paragraph by paragraph
for about 45
different indicators.
And at the point
of trying to say,
which of the big ones,
what changes over time.
But we're just in the
midst of that one sorry.
OK we have one more, that is
a glimmer in a student eye
and I'm totally
supporting this one.
I think this is just fun.
May work, may not.
So helping people
communicate across cultures.
So we already know from a lot of
our research on cross culture,
that people from
different countries,
different habits from in
their local culture, not just
countries, have different
ways of communicating.
We've done a lot of
research about what
do we already out there on this.
We know there's
differences in eye contact,
whether you're supposed to
look at somebody or not.
Whether that means
attention or deference.
There's big differences in
pause structure for example,
in America, we will
wait max two seconds.
So if you end
speaking and if nobody
says anything in two seconds,
you have the floor again.
And then we're all stepping
over everybody sentences.
We don't even finish
our sentences,
somebody else is talking.
That's the American way.
And it turns out
in other countries,
you're supposed to stop and
value what you just heard.
Think about it before you
then give a comment next.
So it's like a
nine second pause.
Imagine those two people
talking to each other.
One doesn't say anything.
Right, because he hasn't waited
long enough for me to say,
this is the time for
me to jump in here.
So one person's
talking all the time.
One person's not talking at all.
And the person who is
talking all the time
thinks the other guy
has nothing to say.
And the guy who has
quote, nothing to say
thinks this guy is rude.
And things go badly.
So that's one. [INAUDIBLE].
Also expressing the negative.
There's a paper study of
long distance collaboration
at Google, that we've
been looking at,
where expressing the negative
is a really hard problems.
For example in India, you don't
say you can't do something.
And yet the people
from the US needed
to know whether
this is beyond what
their time and resources were.
It turns out the
solution is to say,
what more resources do you
need in order to get this done,
as opposed to can
you get this done.
You get a very different
response from that.
But you need to know
these things in order
to have these
convocations go well.
So the thing is to
find a middle ground.
Later I'll look at that
cartoon it's really cute.
OK in some, that's
what we're doing.
We've got a lot of stuff
going on the macro.
A lot of attention on
the micro about what's
going on inside Google
Docs for collaboration.
Looking for indices of quality.
Trying to extend to spreadsheets
and other kinds of documents.
And we need some help.
So if you can
guide us to people,
who can help us with
API, that's critical.
The other is more ideas about
how to visualize some of this
and what's important
to you, when
you use various kinds
of Google applications.
OK.
Thank you.